[Music]
brian collins
is what is known as a legend
in the design world he has either
personally designed or overseen some of
the biggest design projects
he designed the hershey store in times
square
his company redid the branding for
spotify mattel
levi's american express ibm some of the
biggest most powerful companies
he has had significant influence in how
they look
and feel and present themselves to the
outside world
by sheer dumb luck i have known brian
for 20 years
and so i have learned so much from him
just from getting to interact with him
over all these years
and one of the things that i adore about
him
is his ability to think about the future
how we live how we interact with the
world and with each other
so we sat down together and we talked
about
designing the future this
is a bit of optimism
brian collins one of my favorite people
in
the world i want to talk to you about
the future how's my favorite topic
because you more than almost anyone i
know
think about the future live in the
future build the future
plan the future and have shown me
how to do that over the course of a very
long time that you and i have known each
other
20 years or something we've known each
other which makes me just feel old
i met you when i was four
[Laughter]
yeah that means i think i met you i
think i was 62 so
about the time to cancel the starsky and
hutch
[Laughter]
just to give a little context you and i
met when i had a
i wasn't entry level but i was low man
on the totem pole we worked in ogilvy at
may there together
you were the the head of the design
group there i was um
a lowly dog's buddy and there was a huge
new business pitch that the company was
working on that
took a lot of uh people involved from
the agency to participate
and i was assigned to work on this pitch
uh
and i was assigned to work with you yeah
and that's how we met
yeah you became part of my team now i
became part of your team that day flash
forward many many years
we met for lunch and you as a little
gift gave me a copy
of dr james carson's finite and infinite
games
you gave his book many many years ago
a book that profoundly changed the
course of
my life but also changed the way i view
the world because it is
ostensibly about the future it's it's
looking at the future in a way
that that is far more poetic far more
generous far more encompassing
as a metaphor and i thought at the time
since you were looking at the future in
a very big
sort of abundant way it was all mapped
ahead of you you know it was all
potential it was
it was a cargo of possibilities in front
of you that this was a book
that i thought that had a pretty
powerful sort of philosophical bent but
it also had poetry to it
and i thought it would be something that
you would like well i'm super grateful
so growing up did you live in your
imagination were you always thinking
about the future were you a fan of
science fiction was that your thing
well you know it's interesting i think
when you're a young child if you're
creative if you're intensely creative
you learn very early on that your mind
works
like differently from a lot of their
kids and you can do one of two things
about that you can either represent that
and go off
and sort of become insulated and
singular and um
but i come from a big irish family and
within a larger
so we talk with each other all the time
so i was wired to be social
and so what ended up happening is i
think there's a there's a split in me
and i'm not
an extrovert and i'm not an introvert
i'm an amber which means i like being
really really social and i like
really being alone at the same time like
and so
i like hanging out with my family like
hanging out with friends god knows i
love hanging out with my
my crew and everyone on my team but then
there's time where i have to go away and
i think
growing up as i did in the 1960s
everything in 1960 sign was about the
future
you know um john kennedy's speech in
1962 puts the united states on a very
different trajectory
we choose the moon we choose the one not
because it's easy
because it is hard and we will get there
before the end of this decade
decayed right yeah well you know it's
boston brahma
what i saw in front of me was the future
was always arriving
every day whether it was on television
with science fiction
whether it was in disneyland with
tomorrowland whether
it was the mcdonald's that opened up in
boston it looked like it had flown in
from from the year 2025
and it was funny really interesting to
me that the future
of architecture first appeared in retail
like retail architecture because it was
easy to produce coffee shops
car washes drive-throughs that were sort
of emblematic of the world of tomorrow
um and so every morning you would wake
up and like what what is tomorrow going
to bring because all of us
were going to the moon the culture had
to catch up with russia
america thought that the soviet union
was basically an agrarian or
barely a post-agrarian society and the
first three breakthroughs
in the frontier outer space was made by
the soviet union you know from from
spotlight to the first man in space and
the first and the first dog
and the first dog leica and also the
first human being to go into space
outside of the capsule right those are
all inventions driven by the soviet
union they're ahead of us
kind of mathematically and
scientifically effectively by decades
and so we had to catch up so the country
was driven but what and
what did that do for you as a kid so did
you just sit and watch tv did you dream
of going to space
oh i dreamed about all of this i had
space toys i read science fiction
starting when i was 10
so i live in that world because tomorrow
was always coming all the other thing
about the 1960s view tomorrow
was our golden era was going to be ahead
of us not behind us
it was not make america great again
america will be better
than ever people will be better than
ever the world will be yet better than
ever in fact the benchmark was
well if we're going to the moon and we
were
then we can solve fill in the blank we
can solve the vietnam war
we can solve racism we can solve the
common cold
because mankind collectively could do
that
everything else by comparison seemed
solvable so so future orientation
was something that before my childhood a
lot of the kids i grew up with
didn't care but my imagination was
absolutely captured by it
you and i share something in common
which is we're both die-hard optimists
and you know i mean i have my definition
of optimism and i'm very curious what
yours is
one of my definitions of optimism comes
from someone who i grew up with noam
chomsky
nom chomsky's quote was if you assume
that there is no hope
you'll guarantee there will be no hope
if you assume that there is an instinct
for freedom that there are opportunities
to change things there's a possibility
you can contribute
to making a better world so in other
words optimism
he said is a strategy for making a
better future because unless you believe
that the future can be better it's
unlikely you will step up and take
responsibility
for making it so if you assume there's
no hope you guarantee there will be no
hope
my definition is that optimism is not
blind positivity
and it's not naive you know you can live
in darkness you can be in darkness you
can go through hard times but optimism
is the undying belief that the future is
bright
one definition that i like to design is
design is hope
made visible and there's a great quote
by rebecca sullivan and in your book
hope in the dark
hope is not a lottery ticket you can sit
on the sofa and clutch feeling lucky
it is an axe you break down doors with
in an emergency hope should shove you
out the door because it will take
everything you have to steer the future
away from endless war
from the annihilation of the earth's
treasures and the grinding out of the
porn marginal
to hope is to give yourself to the
future and that commitment to the future
of what makes the present
inhabitable oh my goodness i love that
because hope i think is
is to some people this ethereal thing
that is a lottery ticket that you hold
on to and you go i hope i hope it works
out
i hope i win the lottery it is like it
is but i love this idea of hope being an
axe i absolutely do adore that imagery
that makes the present inhabitable
because you can plan
a better future and you and you have the
right to change
things that's the thing it's not it's
not passively waiting for the world to
change around you
but hope and optimism is a battery that
drives the energy
for for positive change so you have this
amazing company
where you have brilliant designers and
strategists and thinkers and doers but
you lose employees
constantly yeah for all the brilliant
design that you do you also i don't know
on purpose or by accident built a
factory because you build these
wonderful people up
to become really desirable in the
marketplace and they leave
and so you're you have this wonderful
young team but they're constantly
leaving
i'm so interested how you build such a
successful business where
it's just people are constantly quitting
to go into greener pastures
well i wouldn't say they're necessarily
greener pastures because they're
different pastures fair enough fair
enough
fair enough they're going on for for big
jobs and more responsibility and getting
yeah i i think i think that's true um i
believe
uh grass is not greener on the other
side and grass is greener where you
water it
yeah fair enough you know so true
i've been a teacher uh first starting
with california college of arts and so
when you're a teacher
you have a different perspective the
object is to make sure that your
students
grow and accelerate and i speak to my
students like i speak with my
employees which is you speak to them
about who they can become not who they
are the other thing i try to do is
i don't hire people for their potential
i hire people for their inevitability
what does that mean
everyone i hire i see them for who they
can become
and who they what isn't that potential
no it means i know they will become
in other words i treat them as if it's
inevitable not potential potential
potentially yes potentially no but if
you treat them and it's inevitable they
will do nothing but succeed
that's a different conversation you tell
somebody you will
not fail it's there's nothing you can do
where you will not fail there's nothing
you can do where the outcome of this
will not be successful
you'll be in good hands everything will
be okay that changes a young person's
mindset so you're teaching them to
envision the future
for themselves always you're teaching
them the confidence
of a bright future the purpose of
collins is not to create
followers of brian collins that's stupid
the purpose of collins is to create more
leaders
now by the way i've had people who
worked with me for 21 years i've also
had people
uh on our team who work here for eight
or nine years we have boomerangers who
come back and that's really interesting
so if you see yourself as a community of
where people come and go
um as long as there's a core group of
people that keep the values in place
then i'm okay that people go off and try
new things you know as long as they send
us postcards
as somebody who lives in the future
designs the future builds the future
teaches young people to have confidence
in the future and themselves how do you
deal with disappointment
not well
[Laughter]
no i wish i could be like well you know
i'm very sad about it but i'm not
because i i have hopes for them so when
something goes sideways just walk me
through that whether a person lets you
down or a project goes sideways or
meeting goes badly how does that show up
well i don't see it as failure
yeah first i see it as it's the best
you could do and it's the best we could
do at that point
so let's if we made a mistake let's
apologize but let's not beat ourselves
up let's
learn from this if we learn from it we
don't make the same mistake
again then i'm okay if we make the same
mistake again then i'm like what the
hell
make new mistakes are you like that with
yourself
because i find the way you know because
no i'm not i'm i beat myself
up to death my worst things is when i
know that i didn't deliver yeah that i
didn't stepped up to the plate or the
standards that i set for my staff
and i come short i will go into a shame
spiral i've got to check out
like why did i do that and then you know
and sometimes when i get like that you
know
the 22 year old brian who set out to
start his own you know his career
doesn't want to talk to me like brian
i'm not talking to you you just piss me
off
but you know it gets back to this idea
of disappointment because disappointed
it is related to the idea of regret and
the thing about regret
is if you look at it and now that i'm
you know
on you know now that i'm on the other
side of 22. um
regret could be a tool
for opening up a smarter future
walk me through that i'm i'm because and
it's face i'm not sure i agree
it's years ago when i was in oberlin
there was a gifted young
designer who worked on my team who found
out how much somebody else was making
and they were both about the same age
this other person i had to get out of a
very famous design company
and so i had to pay him he was probably
made about 25 more at the time
than this other young designer did and
he got wind of it and he came into my
office
and publicly in front of four or five
other people said i demand the same
level or i will quit and
uh my ego was like well you can't say
that to me you can't say that
i said now you're giving me no option
because if because you have to quit
because if i give you
a salary now people will now see that's
how you get salaries by coming in and
doing brinksmanship
i regret having treated uh that designer
in that way and so recently
um when someone had made a mistake that
that would be around
it wasn't a salary issue but someone
came in and acted out of like and this
is young this is a very young designer i
was in my 30s at the time
the design was all full of pins and
vinegar and someone did the same thing a
young designer on my team was all full
of this and dinner
and sort of played brinksmanship with me
and i said i understand
i hear you i understand why this is
difficult why don't we go out and have
uh have a dinner and maybe have a drink
let's think about it you're enormously
important to me and i don't want you to
make a mistake
so i've been through this and i will not
let you make this mistake i'm going to
give you some
options that i think will be good for
you and then we'll make these decisions
together
if you decide to leave good if you
decide to stay good but i've got to give
you these options so you will not
make a mistake okay okay okay and so
what i did because i did not want to go
through their heartbreak looking back at
what i did
life is lived in the moment but it's
understood by looking backwards and so
by the way then he ended up
um he saw his options yeah he calmed
down
it took him two days and he goes yeah
you're right had i made that decision
last 24 hours i would have regretted it
okay i know my job
is to prevent you from making a mistake
or if you
or giving you options so you're acting
so you're choosing your future instead
of reacting against one you'd like
so choose the future do you choose this
he said yes i want to do this and he
still is
he's still a key part of our team i want
to say that again because that's such a
good point to choose a future rather
than reacting against the one you don't
like
correct so it's running towards rather
than running away
that's right he was running away and i
didn't want him to run away i said after
two days if you choose to run away i'll
support you
doing that but let me outline a future
that might be interesting
and we can create it together and we
kicked it back and forth
does it seem interesting to you oh yeah
that's better i didn't know that was
possible
well you didn't know unless we had a
conversation and you wouldn't have been
able to do that had you not screwed it
up a bunch of years earlier
yeah i'm devastated by that choice that
i've made um i let that designer
leave it was it one of the dumbest
things i've ever done i've talked about
this before but i i so love it
which is there's this chinese story
that's told and it's told many ways
but this is the way i know it um of a
young man who's
born with a remarkable ability for horse
riding and everyone in the village says
you're so lucky
and the monk says we'll see and then he
falls off his horse breaks his leg his
career is over and everyone in the
village says you're so unlucky
and the monk says we'll see and then war
breaks out and all the young men are
sent to battle but he can't go because
of his busted leg
and everyone in the village says you're
so lucky and the monk says we'll see
and this is sort of regret like had you
not had that
experience go sideways all those years
ago
and had that what we're calling regret
then you may not have learned the lesson
on how to actually treat someone
properly and with empathy and understand
the emotional side of
these conversations better later
so the question the question is do you
have to go through a regret to grow
yes you do you've no choice wisdom isn't
gained by studying was increasing
gain through reading wisdom is gained
through years
of sometimes pain and regret now the
thing about that too is it's not
something you do it's something
sometimes it's done to you i'm gonna go
back to that hope analogy
which is i think potential for some
people is a lottery ticket they're
holding on to
right which is somebody once told them
you have potential
and now they walk around holding on to
it well
well if you're always loaded with
potential um then you don't have to
choose because you're always the person
on their way to somewhere incredible
where inevitability to me
you know is that ax which is which is
strangely enough it's not inevitable
unless unless you're unless you're
plowing forwards
from very early in in my career i always
chose who i was going to work for
rather than what or where i was going to
work for
and i took lower paying job offers
because i
really liked who my boss was going to be
versus the higher paying job and the
fancier account
who they were fine like the team was
fine
but i wasn't inspired or enamored by
them and i remember that traditional hr
question so simon
what are you looking for when i'm being
interviewed and i would always say the
same thing i
i said the thing that i'm looking for is
a lot like looking for love i'd say
which is i'm looking for a mentor and i
literally went from job
to these jobs looking for somebody who
would teach me
and this goes back to what you were
saying before which is one of the
greatest
assets you have as a leader is you're
also a teacher
and it raises the question should all
people in leadership positions in senior
leadership positions
should they also teach will that make
somebody a better leader
well i think there are people who are
natural leaders and i'm certainly not
one when i started collins it was very
clear to me
in the process of doing it that i became
more excited
about seeing other people create things
that they had
they had no understanding that they
could create
that level of work and see young people
manifest work or ideas or writing or
potentials that they didn't know they
could
is far more interesting to me than
anything that i could create one of my
favorite things about our friendship is
because we've known each other for so
long and because we've actually
because i met you professionally yeah is
i can actually
remember who you were as a leader 20
years ago
i know exactly and who you are as a
leader now
and it's fun i think because we i think
we can say this about each other which
is
because we've been friends constantly
for 20 years it's not like we took a
break
you've always been a genius and you've
always had a perspective on the world
that is
is unique and illuminating you've always
had that
that has always been something that has
astounded me about being in a room with
you
but i remember back in the day back in
the day no no
you're always the smartest guy in the
room but back in the day
it became abundantly clear that you it's
not that you wanted to tell us it's that
you just had all these ideas that you
did tell us and you
you dominated rooms oh yeah and you
and you were polarizing people loved you
and hated you back in the day even
you know you you were the genius that
you know and some people had issues with
it and some people didn't
what sitting in meetings with you now
it's a totally different experience
a lot really that's interesting totally
different experience you're still the
smartest guy in the room
but it's amazing how much you defer
and it's amazing how much when somebody
asks you your opinion
you go well let's ask stacey her opinion
first
it's an amazing thing to see was this
organic was this an evolution
or was there another regret is there
something that happened
that pushed you in this direction as an
evolving and growing leader
well the thing about the thing is about
hiring young people i have a nose for
talent i think i'm i like and i think
you do we can you don't have to
we don't need to temper that statement
you have remarkably talented people who
work with you
yeah but the thing about them is we're
kind of i think of a nose for talented
misfits
you know for people who we seem that
collins we all seem to get along with
we all seem to belong with each other
because we don't seem to belong at the
moment
anywhere else and i've been very very
lucky
about that and i think what starts to
happen right the two kinds of people the
kind of people who divide the world into
two kinds of people and those who don't
right
um but there are two kinds of leaders i
think
there are those who kind of like uh an
architecture like frank
lloyd wright and there's the grand
master and the guru and you learn how to
design
like frank lloyd wright you have an
incredibly you know game-changing
philosophy
about uh nature about the the importance
of
design how the world and the world you
lived in and
and and the materials and the habitat
you were surrounded by
about you informed it and how it
informed you and led to some of the most
remarkable pieces of architecture in the
world including fallen water and the
guggenheim museum of new york
they feel inevitable and that's one way
of of being a design leader there's
another way of being a design leader
which is uh which is how jim henson did
it because we
we worked in the design of the jim
henson um exhibit who created the
muppets
and was one of the co-creators of sesame
street as henson
realized his own talent was amplified
accelerated complemented
dimensionalized color was added to it
musicality was added to it
when he brought in collaborators who are
very different than him and the muppets
exist
because of that collision of forces that
he
that he didn't know about and so the
muppets even though it said jim henson
associates the muppets is a
manifestation
of 30 40 50 kinds of musicians and
writers and composers and
illustrators um clowns performers actors
cinematographers and he went out to find
people who were infinitely better than
he was and as a result
what they did together they never could
have done anyone
under frank lloyd wright frank lloyd
wright knows with talent but he was also
looking for
people who were obsequious you know who
would follow his lead
who gifted but were willing to you know
to go okay that's
you want it to be that way and i always
found it much more interesting as i
progressed in my career
overly is that i found there were people
who were enormously more talented
than i was in design in writing like oh
my god
we can actually do more stuff if we hire
people who are different than
than i am who are not like me this is
important this is important
because we started talking about the
future right and the building of the
future
and when you're a frank lloyd wright as
genius as you are you die
and for the rest of time we we are
forced to repair and put your
your work in formaldehyde so that we can
look back on it
where you have your jim henson's and
your walt disney's who surrounded
themselves with people who are far bet
and those companies
with their leaders long gone with their
founders long gone
continue to innovate and and pave the
way in their industries
but because of the people he built
around them and so the the inevitability
of
hope of hope as an acts
yes requires us the humility
this is very interesting that it
requires the humility to surround
ourselves with people who are a lot
better than we are
and different and different and
different
there are people in my team who are not
particularly not particularly good
writers
they might not be as fluent in
conversation about strategy
but if you give them the brief and the
and the brief is inspiring and
open-ended enough
they will absorb their brief and they
will create things that you will
blow your mind and so
you have to have to recognize they're
going to be different kinds of
intelligences different kinds of
energies
you have to create people who are you
have to create room for people who are
insanely introverted um who may even be
by every definition somewhere
on the spectrum whatever that means um
as well as people who are alphas who are
going to go out and help you you know
win the day in a massive project
the culture has to accommodate all sorts
of different energies
we do not i despised
despise the term cultural fit
what a pernicious word you don't fit get
out
really you don't fit leave it is such a
cover it is such a tiny fig leaf
for people to hide behind any kind of
music i don't like you it can hide all
sorts of things
racism homophobia um you know all sorts
of all sorts of fears
where we hire for what we would say is
cultural contribution what do you bring
how are you different how can you add to
our tapestry
with something we don't have how can you
do how can you bring something to us
that's different so we try hire for
people who are not
a fit but who couldn't who contribute to
something and then
the culture has to then accommodate them
i like this because the culture
absolutely is a set of values
right yeah there is such thing as
fitting the culture but what i love
is this terminology of seeing someone as
a fit absolutely has a
pernicious side to it but what i like is
fit is is passive right
like you're you're a square we have a
place for a square over here
square peg square hole ta-da
right there you go versus contribution
which is a growth mindset with its
contribution which is we're growing
we're we're expanding we're amplifying
and we need whatever it is you have to
help us amplify it goes back to
frank lloyd wright do you fit are you
you know will you be the square peg that
i need in the square hole at this moment
to serve
to serve me or are you going to do
something that's going to challenge me
and make me uncomfortable jim henson
walt disney
uh and look what we can build together
that i couldn't do without you that's
that's cultural contribution i really
really like that
for us to think of someone as a
potential cultural contributor
rather than a fit what you bring that we
don't have yeah how's your voice
different how is your personality
different
how can you yeah and i'm gonna even
tweak my language again not as a
potential cultural contributor an
inevitable cultural contribution
inevitable
yes i'm once again a prisoner of
language thank you
you you spot my achilles heel no i'm
with you
it's i mean like but i think changing
words i mean you and i both know this
changing the words we use actually
matters it sure does
there's a proverb i think or statement i
think i think it comes from the ivory
coast
i might be wrong but it says if you want
to go summer fast go alone if you want
to go somewhere far go together yeah
right but that means there's they're
going to be certain kinds of things that
you do
with the people a bunch of people who
are going to go together there's going
to be arguments there's going to be
difficulties because you have to
accommodate particularly
if you want to accommodate enormously
talented
and uncommonly gifted people like like
like we have
at our company and they tend to be
ambitious they tend to want to run
fast and get things done make stuff
talented people love to get stuff
out the door one of the things that
we've had to do and this is sometimes
the other thing i've learned is that
there are people who uh
love to talk and there are people who
love to do and then their people love to
do both
i think there's a huge mistake in the
business press in in the writing about
business and the studying of leadership
sure and it's and it's this which is we
spend too much time studying the
companies who are quote unquote big
successful fast growing where the
leaders have outsized egos
you know for all for all the reasons and
i think we're missing an opportunity to
study the creative companies you know
yes there's been books written by
you know about disney and about henson
but they tend to be read by
people from those industries are from
creative people like the like
everybody in the world isn't reading
about jim henson like they read about
you know general electric you know
they're writing books about
google and twitter and amazon but but i
think studying creative companies
theater companies dance companies
yours a design company where where the
idea of hiring
misfits and hiring for contribution and
high and by the way hiring introverts
and how you create space for an
introvert who is insanely
talented but it's really important if
you're building a creative company where
you want to be on the frontier of things
all the time and we always want to be on
the frontier so i have to make space and
i sense
this person might have something it gets
back to this puzzle
i think and i've seen this an awful lot
and i've seen and i've i've been falling
victim to this because
i like people who are intelligent
hyper-articulate and charismatic
and i fall for it more often than not is
if you're not careful and i don't do
this anymore i used to do it a lot when
i started collins
is a high i would hire articulate
incompetence
and a market and the marketing
industries
shock a block with them people who can
talk blue streak don't know how to write
a deck
don't know how to design it don't know
how to design a damn thing i can't write
it i've hired
i've i've hired some of those companies
oh and they and they go
yeah and more of this more that
advertising marketing is filled with
them yeah and they can't they don't have
ideas but
man can they talk a blue streak man can
they sell you
you know they can sell ice in minnesota
in january when it throws 30 degrees
below zero um and snow drifts
and they're like and and i and i fall
victim to this yeah it's true i i have
two
articulate incompetence i think yeah
that is that that sums up the ad
industry
particular competency is right and you
you see them
and they're and they get and the other
flip side is they get fame and mastery
confused or conflated and so what we try
to do
is um is is i i i see this with with
young creative people often because they
get they get fame um
you know because of instagram godness
tick tock pinterest all the places
that they're posting they can become
very very famous
but but you don't have to be very very
good there are
less great masterful creative people but
not all of them are famous
and so um what i try to do is not
complete the two and i'm very interested
in mastery mastery is a long game this
is so
interesting to me i've learned so much
about what it takes to build the future
and the idea of hiring for cultural
contribution
the idea of looking for misfits and
offering them the inevitability of their
own future
and it's really a confidence grain right
helping them build the confidence and
putting them in uncomfortable positions
and
letting them know that they can't fail
because they're full of they're
surrounded by people who want to see
them succeed and support and feel
supported
who will not let them will not let them
fail and and
if they have a setback then it's simply
a lesson and we'll get through this
together you know
because not everything goes according to
plan no and you know god does we
we make mistakes some people you know we
like for whatever reason
there is no greater statement of
optimism
than to think about the future as an
inevitable
positive place i don't use the word the
teacher i use the word the futures
because there's no such thing as the
future all futures are in competition
with each other all the time the future
i thought was going to be inevitable in
the year 2016
i sat with 15 members of my team i saw
that teacher
collapse in november 2016. i'm like what
that feature was not inevitable and i
thought it was all teachers are in
competition with other features
all the time you have to choose which
feature are you going to invest in but
then it's not inevitable is it
no no no no what i'm saying is they're
they're trajectory to be self-actualized
in my mind
is inevitable i love this i love there's
no such thing as i'm going to say it
again because i love it
there's no such thing as the future no
there are futures
and all of these ideas of what the
future could be are in competition
and this is unshapeable which is why we
have to show up
in life with an axe and not a lottery
ticket because the future that we get to
live in is the one that we
that we will have to build and bash down
doors to see happen
and that and the one that you believe is
worth fighting for and the one that you
believe is worth fighting for
amen to that brian i could talk to you
for hours thank you so much for doing
this with me
this is so good every time i talk to you
i learn something new
i really do i love it well simon the
same thing about how he dudes it was
great
how do i say this we talked about regret
right i've learned two things if i've
learned anything at all is the power of
regret
to be a sort of a tiller to help you
avoid
the same mistakes yeah and you can i use
it in some ways as a bit of a sale
to find help me make better decisions
yeah and the second thing i've learned
about
probably more than anything else the
secret of long-term great relationships
is the secret of long-term
romantic relationships and it's not
respect it's not
delight it's not confidence it's not
it's
endless endless endless forgiveness
and saying okay we'll we'll try it next
time and let's get up
and do it again tomorrow yeah that's
true
i love you brian i really do i'll talk
to you soon
if you enjoyed this podcast and you'd
like to hear more please subscribe
wherever you like to listen to podcasts
until then take care of yourself take
care of each other